[Musique]
c'est qu'il y a des millions de mètres
carrés vacants en France et en parallèle
prise du logement surtout dans les
grandes métropoles où bah pour la
plupart des jeunes il est très compliqué
de se loger et c'est un problème qui est
d'autant plus marqué chez les personnes
réfugiées qui en sortie de centre
d'hébergement d'urgence ont beaucoup de
difficultés à trouver à trouver un une
solution de de logement à la
suite je viens
d'arriver c'est arrivé en France octobre
2018 des PS cette période là j'étais
j'étais à chez des amis des
connaissances et pendant 5 ans j'ai
habité à plusieurs appartements à Paris
et en autre ville j'ai déménagé plus que
je sais pas plus que 90 je pense 10 fois
et bah j'ai cherché plusieurs fois j'ai
demandé à logement social mais j'avais
pas de la chance
deavoir jusque il y a 2
semaines
[Musique]
mettre le prix c'est sûr que ça joue
personnellement je paye 297 € tout frais
inclus assez cool de se ler dans un
projet où tu pas forcément vu l'endroit
où tu vas habiter tu sais pas je
connaissais pas le quartier je
connaissais pas mes colocques et et rien
depuis que je suis arrivée j'ai
rencontré plein de plein de personnes
que j'aurais pas du tout rencontré dans
ma vie
[Musique]
quotidienne
là au programme il y a de la peinture de
l'arrachage de papier peint la
construction de meubles en bois qui ont
été designés par un des
[Musique]
colocataires
on fait du logement trempelin l'idée
c'est de pouvoir se poser pendant un an
et lancer ces projets là pour qu'en
sortie de en fin de projet les personnes
bah et une situation peut-être un peu
plus stable pour trouver une solution de
logement pérenne à la
[Musique]
suite il man juste